well look we'll see we'll see what
happens to the elon stuff but it's
friday night and i think it's time we we
get to the the more fun story here
here we go ladies and gentlemen from
newsweek
joe biden mocked for a parent
teleprompter flub repeat the line yo
this is amazing you ready for this one
let's play it is noteworthy that the
percentage of women who registered to
vote and cast a ballot is consistently
higher than the percentage of the men
who do so end of quote repeat the line
women are not without
repeat the line the men who do so end of
quote repeat the line end of quote
repeat the line here's the funny thing
you ready for this
newsweek reports he's mocked for an
apparent teleprompter flub
end of quote is not the first time he
has read that okay and guess who
fact-checked it as false also newsweek
amazing fact check did joe biden
accidentally read teleprompter
instruction during speech this is from
november 2021 november 24th
false the phrase end of quote was not a
teleprompter instruction accidentally
read by biden it was part of the speech
used to bookend the walmart ceo's remark
which biden began citing seconds earlier
with the phrase to quote the walmart ceo
how many people have you ever met who go
and i was talking to the texas who said
quote i enjoy going uh to the mall to
shop end of quote sometimes i'll say
close quote but that's the course or end
quote it is
typically people just say quote that's
usually for like an audio book yeah
something really formal yeah yeah i
think the reality is
they put that in there as instructions
right and repeat the line because
they're supposed to pull it back and
then biden just ron burgundy is it at
the very least it's not the phrase end
of quote that's in contention it's the
phrase repeat the line
and then and then i didn't do it and
right and he didn't do it and a white a
white house staffer said he actually
said let me repeat the line oh he didn't
say no i i they actually tweeted that's
crazy that's what they said they're
gaslighting and you know why they do
that
because what's going to happen now is
the media will say
conservatives accuse joe biden of x
white house says why and people who
don't pay attention to pay attention to
the news will see that story and not the
fact that joe biden read the prompter
like ron burgundy and that they're
trying not to laugh in the background
that was the best part how does
not laugh around her face changes
look at the guy on the right he's trying
not to laugh
look at him he's like i hope he doesn't
mess this up i think i think kamala is
just like you think she'll write a book
like my time as the vp yeah
i want to mention who do you know who
this guy on the right is is that looks
like rob emmanuel maybe no that's not
the name he does kind of look like him i
mean
the guy on the right is like holding
back laughing kamala harris i can
imagine what's going on in their heads
the guy in the right in his head he's
like don't laugh don't laugh don't laugh
kamala harris in her mind
because look at her face she's just like
when you hear her talk she just says
words
one of the replies to this was like
she says he repeated the line because
the line was there and he wanted to say
it again because he needed to repeat the
line
like that's how she talks
this is why they gave him instructions
that said you do this you do this
because if you don't oh right
that's that's that's great yeah so
that's that simon says game remember
that
you is so big on the card right so he
doesn't actually read it that explains
it so he had a card and it said you
stand up you talk to the press you ask
because when you don't put that there he
actually just does exactly verbatim
yo this guy is not all with it no do you
think he's on drugs yeah oh yeah of
course but uppers uppers yeah yeah this
dude's probably on so much meth i just
saw a video of him from like four years
ago i'm not saying like he's smoking
crystal i'm saying yeah
adderall and other uppers other math
derivatives and things like that
those are amphetamines yeah adderall's
not meth it's different amphetamines but
right some kind of okay i should say
meth some amphetamine i'll say but it's
funnier to say meth
honestly it's funnier to think that he's
just smoking like son he's got the blue
stuff from from walter white they was
giving him a good good stuff doing that
good good oh yeah
they would have him sleep for 20 hours
and wake up right before
then they would give him an iv drip of
some real legit upper he's just on
another planet yeah dude his eyes were
like his pupils are dilated he's like i
can see everything were his eyes
bleeding a few yeah
like terrifying and then pair that with
his like cheshire cat's smile
i remember when his eye popped on stage
yeah yeah like a blood vessel or
something crazy was that you think i was
drug induced because i've never seen it
happen before since well stress maybe
just straight it can be a lot of things
but drugs can induce stress as well you
know what i think it really was like
because it popped before he went on
stage right i'm not no i think it popped
on stage you sure i think so because i
was gonna say he was probably making a
boom boom and he's old man
for real let it happen you know that's
terrible you guys watch the new one
i'm sorry didn't he poo his pants in
front of the pope or something that's a
story okay i heard that story but is
that confirmed fact check
okay here we go you guys we got it
snopes has got the truth okay did biden
poop his pants in rome
another president another pants pooping
rumor
false
well hold on there a minute there was a
rumor that trump did the same what the
heck that was a rumor that trump hired
lady women of the night to relieve
themselves on a bed that's a little i
mean yeah but snopes is funny like when
they do the fact check this like yes
there were traces of feces in his
underwear
but it wasn't a full poop so therefore
false right that's what they do
they say an actual rumor is not a fact
oh okay oh that explains it so look at
this uh he says there's no evidence his
claim
the claim wasn't derived from photos or
biden the story was that
joe biden was apparently uh having some
meeting and then mysteriously went
absent for a short amount of time and
then came back wearing some other
clothes or something
and everyone's like he pooped his pants
and i'm like i agree i don't know if he
actually did
like remember the the pissy kid used to
come to school with an extra pair of
pants yeah when he's like in like
kindergarten
bro had to clean himself up
i've been watching the um the secretary
what is this her job the woman the press
sector yeah the press secretary she
speaks for him this new girl and she
says um a lot i want to get ahead what
is her name
i don't know what the new black lady
yeah what's her name i only remember
redhead yeah that was jen sackey yeah
she was in suffering
she just keeps this woman karine is her
name yeah oh man i want to point out
that she says um way too much
yeah she says things that just aren't
true way too much and she also says i
don't know way too much oh what about
hunter biden's laptop i have no idea you
gotta talk to hunter biden's gotta talk
to the white house about that it's um
but jen sackey would say we're gonna
circle back to that right she was way
better they don't circle back yeah well
saki had more experience
you know when you're like a well
seasoned communist like lions just comes
with the territory exactly well it's
it's like
when you look into their eyes you don't
see a soul and it's just they're
programmed they can say whatever they
need to with a straight face
yeah i mean i mean
just the blatant line
that the left
the left conducts is just egregious oh
remember remember remember when uh jack
basoba got punched yes and then the cops
walked up having witnessed it and that
fat antifa woman goes nothing happened
yeah it's just like those eyes dude
those evil lying eyes
there's not a trace that they're
doubting what they're saying like they
really are believing no no they know
they're lying she she was like smirking
like nothing happened i didn't see
anything and the cops were like yeah we
witnessed it we're resting like lying is
good if you're lying against an evil
entity like the nazis where where are
you hiding the jews and you're like i
don't have any jews in this house but
you are hiding people that you're saving
that you're you're a liar but you're
doing it so these people probably are
just so what they think well that's what
saul lelinski says right that ends
justified it means
some people believe all lying is
unethical
yeah regardless of consequences or
circumstances i don't know
maybe jordan peterson like what if what
if you know like i'd like what if what
if shots
like what if your kid is like
you know mom am i attractive what's the
mom going to say yo you're ugly
i did that once to my kid man oh how was
it
it was terrible oh my gosh
he came to me he said he drew like this
this picture
and he's a young boy and he was like
seven or eight at the time he said dad
what do you think this picture and i
asked him i said do you want to know the
truth of what i think and he looked me
and i said yeah i want to know the truth
i said bro that [ __ ] is ugly
and he started breaking down crying i'm
like i'm such an idiot i am so stupid
like is this what i'm saying i was
supposed to lie duh did you like give
him specific criticisms like that nose
is too big no after you started crying i
was like man i'm just playing bro that
[ __ ] is dope
no but you you don't like if it's if
it's a little kid and they're trying you
know you don't got to say that's
terrible you just feel like
you're doing really well you do you want
to improve but the way he said it was
like he wanted constructive feedback
right like i was trash
i was in i was hanging out with uh three
grown adults and we were having a
conversation about the grown folk stuff
and i said can i provide some criticism
and he says we don't use the word
criticism here it's called constructive
feedback so you know you're definitely
dealing with some democrat
they have to make it as verbose as
possible yeah as if it like softens the
offense so what do you think is the best
thing with a kid that wants the truth
like are you like well i don't like it
but let me tell you why
this line's a little crooked you could
do this a little straighter you have a
lot of goo and then give him a
compliment sandwich like i don't know
kids understand the complexities of that
yeah no you just say you know what
you're on your way to great art awesome
you're gonna be awesome this is a great
start you just gotta go with that you
know we're still honest but it's not
saying right you know
or you can mix it up a little bit and be
like you're on your way to being really
really great you keep working at this
you're gonna be fantastic
the honest truth is you're no rembrandt
right not yet yeah so so but you got to
keep that's pretty hard
it's pretty harsh but you're no
rembrandt
no i'd say it's more of a monet not
monet
and then if your kid actually knows
anything about art they're like
cringe how dare you you're more of a
picasso you know because you're more of
a jacksonville really ugly just like you
did the next picasso that's what you can
do you can you can be like he's a famous
artist you know jackson pollock right so
when your son writes draws trash you can
just be like well you know
some people like it so the the press
secretary is treating us like a little
kid that she doesn't want to make start
crying but being like the economy is in
shambles and we're like oh
yeah
it's great if the economy is fantastic
yeah you're doing great you're gonna be
fine i don't know that's what they were
lying about the whole uh ukraine i'm
gonna not a lot of say that here on
youtube but
the whole gas right like oh gas prices
are low because putin and it's just like
what like
right right gas prices are high because
of putin right
they're low in russia but right
but they lied about that right like and
and then they they used brittany griner
as a political pawn and said she's
locked up because putin is like no she's
locked up because she broke a law just
just stop and think about how amazing
this is gas prices are skyrocketing
people are complaining about gas prices
going up yeah then one day putin invades
ukraine and biden goes oh those gas
prices it's putin and all these
democrats go oh
that explains it and we're like dude
that just happened the price of gas was
already already right and they're like
no that's putin
it's like okay man yeah everybody's
looking for the villain who's the
villain who's the villain something bad
who's this villain there's gotta be a
villain because of this this is what i
imagine that that fat auntie for a woman
when jack paco got punched and she looks
at him and she's like i didn't see
anything and you it's like she got that
smart on her face remember when that
struck guy whatever his name is
peter yes and he's testifying as a thing
with his eyes
and christine blasey ford does it too
these people like envision themselves as
like gi joe villains that's what it
looks like like
it's like you're acting like you're evil
dude do they believe they're
on the side of good though i don't know
maybe they think they're villains the
guy that said that we need to protect
the liberal world order it was pretty
much like i think he thinks he's on the
side of good
but that the side of good is the liberal
world is like global military american
dominance so that means his boss has
completely got him conditioned and
brainwashed i just yeah he's
like literally
creme de la creme of the sheep but i'm
wondering these days like you know the
liberal warlord or you're familiar for
the century do you know much about no
it's like the in 1946 they built it
after world war ii they're like we could
never have another world war we need to
set up military bases around the world
we're going to use the american military
as the forefront we're going to use the
american economy and it's like a global
the um industrial military industrial
complex basically so now they called it
the new world order george bush senior
was like we're going to set up a new
world order and they're talking about
improving this liberal order this
liberal world order and it's basically
there's this or there's like the chinese
world order which is bricks uh brazil
russia china india south africa
um so it's like we're gonna have one
world order another i mean we might be
able to to resist and have like a
decentralized union which is ideal in my
opinion but
right now we have these world competing
world orders and it's like do we support
the the liberal one or do we just
i wrote a book on a world order okay uh
it's called the patriot report i'm
asking the conspiracy of money in war
and there was this funny part in my book
about the bretton woods agreement and
and how they were able to convince the
united states to be um the reserve
currency for these nations
and that was pretty
uh eye-opening studying the brentwood's
agreement in keynes and how they put
this together and then how
that led into uh
i would call hyperinflation of the
dollar i think that's 1971 that happens
when it
brentwood's agreement basically
dissolves but that that when i looked at
the brentwood's agreement like i think
that was 1944 brentwood's agreement
somebody got to look that up um don't
give me the line but it lines up with
what you said like that whole world
order around that same time period so
now when you say it i'm like maybe
there's some connectedness there it's
falling apart 1944. yeah that's 44.
there you go when when epstein
is mainstream like the whole episode
story when maxwell's being publicly
sentenced they won't reveal the client
list
when the georgia guidestones are blown
up
when they're shooting at farmers
meanwhile there's a food shortage coming
you know the narrative is collapsing i
understand the hatred of the patriarchy
that like oh we've got these old roman
guys basically trying to own everyone
through religion and through you know
whatever god is a man all this nonsense
but like
it doesn't mean that just destroying it
is the way to go because there's much
worse things out there as well we got to
keep that in mind yeah chinese communism
is very dangerous the ccp is very
dangerous the citizens are like on
lockdown 24 they're like thanks for
checking out this segment from the tim
cast irl podcast but if you want to
check out the full show live tune in
monday through friday at 8pm and if you
want more special access content head
over to timcast.com and become a member
your membership helps sustain this
company keep our journalists employed
makes this show happen and you will get
access to exclusive members only
segments of the tim cast irl podcast and
there's a massive library to check out
so again go to timcast.com or tune in
monday through friday at 8pm we'll see
you all there